[Music]
today no you know no you look like a
pumpkin the cutest pumpkin I've ever
seen I am running through my supply of
onesies cool today
what kind of ones these are they let me
in these get yourself some me andis
right now force me to segue good same
thing they saw the best three times
softer than cotton underwear and the
best onesies ever that money can buy go
to me undies that's Emmie und IES calm
/gen and Julien to get 15% off your
first pair of free shipping and 100%
satisfaction guaranteed you will be
satisfied let go
we're quick link down below also guys
post mates post mates as the incredible
delivery app that delivers all your
favorite restaurants and food right -
you just download the post mates app for
a limited time
they're giving you a hundred and ten
dollars guys a hundred and ten dollars
of free delivery credit for your first
seven days okay so start your free
deliveries go download the app and use
code Jeanette Julian that's just our
name Jenna Julian it's also in the
description check it out awesome app
awesome sponsors thank you suppose I
tell you I know you know but so because
I have been exclusively wearing mm-hmm
me and these onesies corns yes
I do know that I was like I would like
to expand my supply of onesies because
it is so comfortable especially when you
chillin in gaming you know they're great
gaming outfits
it is the gaming outfit the only thing I
would if you know me and ease you know
engineers over here if you want to
listen I have an idea a pouch for snacks
no you can put on an external pouch oh
okay maybe like a scramble so I went on
the me undies website to like actually
order another onesie I wanted some bra
let's
uh I look at their website I did not
realize that they had dresses and
rompers they're all sold out by the way
in the rompers cuz I was you were just a
being customer and trying to buy them
because the material is so soft and nice
but like I wanted a romper they don't
have any but I bought a dress and it is
so cute it is cute it's it's it's
definitely dress rather which makes me
happy cuz they get to see you in a dress
and that has a really cute looking at my
legs never stop looking at my legs
literally never stopping I'm gonna look
at your legs right now that's what I
feel like when I'm wearing any shorts or
dress or anything I'm comfortable I'm
happy but to the world stop looking at
my legs just pretend they're not there
I'm excluded from them know where the
works stop looking at my legs thank you
oma sneak a peek but yet me Andes has
more than just onesies and undies they
they have other stuff I saw someone in
chat the other day
cuz you walked behind me and you're
wearing the pumpkin onesie and they were
like all right Jenna just decided it's
October y'all I'm I face I my niece and
nephew and they both thought it was a
very funny they were big fans yeah
impress you nice nephew dude be a poke
your nephew is so [ __ ] cute isn't he
the funniest he we were facetiming and
they he does this thing where he raises
his hand like he's in class to get
called on he raised his hand and then
when he gets called on he does his
little dance every single time and this
dance is just the cutest thing I've ever
seen
well I don't think he knows like you
raise your hand because you have
something to say but he doesn't have
anything to say no he just he wants it
to be like about me about me no hmm so
he raises his hand he gets called on and
he delivers know now that I'm on the
spot I better do it is oh he lives for
that moment kids the funny oh man he is
so cute yeah so anyway we're gonna do
some quizzing today we we did look and
we know we've done a million years ago
we did the office on YouTube
trivia as a podcast but that was very
very surface level quiz that we're
talking about here okay I am NOT a
surface level viewer of that show I'm
also still on vacation so I'm gonna do
the quizzing today well I'm gonna take
the quiz she's gonna do the question you
on vacation and you not even here I'm
not poking it's like that episode of the
office when he makes a paper mache
version of himself so that when people
walk into his office it'll look like
he's sleeping and then Stanley goes I
don't get it why is you sleeping at your
desk better than you being not here I
don't understand why you would make a
paper mache anything as a solution to
anything at all do you know how long it
takes to make a paper mache thing is the
most true statement I've ever heard it's
not a solution to anything it's a time
sighs yeah it's awful and it's messy and
your hands get wet and then it hardens
and it's just the worst
it definitely took him like two days to
make a fake paper mache him and then
paint it and like let it you know the
art department had their work cut out
for them for sure um did I ever tell you
that I won an ice cube igloo contest
when I was in like first or second grade
we had to make an igloo for an ice cube
and whoever's ice cube lasted the
longest one and I won out of my entire
class and I used paper mache that's
really it was this little tiny red house
and my mom dude I came home with his
assignment my mom was like we got this
move aside and we [ __ ] paper mache
this tiny little house and then we lined
it with cotton and then we put the ice
cube in it and it lasted like so much
longer than everyone else we just smoked
everyone Wow they didn't even [ __ ]
want these first grade hands didn't
wanna that's really funny
because what I'm trying to think of a
time when I brought my you know was my
dad's a chemist any time I brought my
homework home my dad was like let's
[ __ ] do it but the only thing that
really comes to mind is like when I
first started like I had a paper like my
first paper assignment and I was on my
dad's house and I showed it to my dad
and he was like oh no no no I was like
what's wrong dad he was like she's play
sure
and I was like what's plagiarize Jenna
if you're writing about something you
can't just take a paragraph from the
book and like what I was like what
that's what that paper I don't know how
else to say it what do you mean write a
paper yeah and that's how I learned how
to cite sources no he taught me how to
like take information and turn it into a
thought got it it was like right about I
was you know some 1700s Spanish explorer
or something I was like dad this is what
the book says what do you mean turn it
history dad that's funny
it's like such a funny specific moment
how to write a paper because it's not an
innate thing no it's a learned thing for
sure yeah that's so funny
I just remember him being like this is
like what is that word what do you say
you keep saying plagiarize it's not a
big deal I don't know what that word is
that's not a big deal I'm just I'm
braiding with the book says it's correct
I assure you it's correct good I wonder
like how many more of those moments I
could just like remember from thinking
about [ __ ] like those weird pivotal
moment that you just they stick with you
you know or like those are the moments
that stuck with me but like as a parent
what are the funny like tiny little
miniscule moments that you remember or
forget like all the funniest stupidest
person like this is the moment in time
that I learned how to write a paper
mm-hmm what what what are the moments
that my parents remember yeah that was a
long moment in time I learned how to
paper mache a house or when I when I got
rejected from the AP art program that
was the moment rejected from the AP art
program doesn't make you a bad artist I
just loved I've talked about this on the
podcast so I'm not gonna go into it but
I just love thinking back to how bummed
I was that I didn't get an AP art when
it was like in reality APR in high
school like what a subjective [ __ ]
and thing that is right you're talking
to a bunch of high schoolers who all
want to be in a serious art program and
you're gonna take some of them can say
now trash rejected and I'm like okay I
guess I'm bad I mean that's what
happened like if you major in art in
college right or some sort of emphasis
in art or some type of art like you go
to the class you sign for the class to
pay for the class you take your class
and I so they're like no get away from
me know what another specific moment
okay my stepmother was an art teacher
and she was such like she went to school
she studied art she was so lovely and we
loved her so much and she still I mean
she is so lovely and I remember we love
spending time with her because she would
always teach us how to do like arts and
crafts and so we had such a good time me
in particular because IB Crafton mhm I
was drawing one time and I'm at a I
cannot draw I'm bad at it and I just
remember sitting there and like trying
to draw like a building or something and
I was drawing an animal and with some
grass and she was like I'm like is this
good
like Margaret do you like it she was
like so when you look at a bunny what do
you see you know I was like well fur and
she's like looking to interview fur I'm
like oh yeah I guess you're right she's
like what is fur look like it I was like
I don't know she's like you can try to
be like this you know and she's like
physically teaching me and showing me
how to draw you know and then she'll do
like a little bit and oh my gosh [ __ ]
that looks so good and then I just sort
of like keep doing that so I can take
credit for it
that's so funny and honestly conspiracy
you do draw a really good bunny is that
why that's literally the only thing I
know how to draw any time I draw
it's like your go-to you draw the bunny
but it has no fur yeah it's an outline
there is no fur on that bunny first hard
to draw fur hair those are probably the
most difficult things to draw I would
say yeah but they're not they're just
it's basically like if someone were like
hey
you know that thing that everyone has
about 10,000 of draw them perfectly so I
can understand what it looks like yeah
yeah it was funny though yeah that is
for me what is it buddy anyway he helped
me a lot
yeah all right still [ __ ] but same your
are it's much better than mine that's
just a little little better [ __ ] decent
[ __ ] anyway do you want to quiz me Home
Office now I guess if I have to
well here's the thing right we were
talking by the way last I just wanted to
shout out you guys last week I was going
through the comments and you guys were
[ __ ] droppin some really good ideas
and the the thing I love about when you
drop ideas in the YouTube comments of
here in the podcast is they get [ __ ]
the good ones get shot up to the top and
everyone's like yes great idea and then
give them one of these so it helps me
because some I mean no offense but
sometimes if I'm on Twitter I'm like
give me some progress it is you're like
I have win over lassic but you give me
some [ __ ] ideas alright
I'm being real with you so last week you
guys hit the comment section hard with
great ideas you had a bunch of them
screenshot at some of them for future
episodes but this was I think this was
one of them when you tweeted though
people don't give you ideas they just
say water sermon water sermon have Jenna
paint an upside-down face on her face
while you listen to music while you
watch Nicolas Cage how are we it's funny
they're just they're making you laugh I
know I love them so I I looked I looked
around actually I making fun of Twitter
but I did go on Twitter to get some help
getting the most difficult office quiz
we could find and I think we've done
that so we have an office quiz where you
have to write in your answers which
we're gonna do first
you're gonna write it in on my phone no
I'm gonna tell you what's right I have
to write it is it called the office
difficult trivia quiz I don't know are
there spaces to write an answer I can't
do it on mobile what I can't do it on
mobile good no I can't no don't do this
to
oh it's you gotta play quiz okay I
didn't want to press it because I wasn't
playing marble I don't I don't know
where you came from marble jump up all
of sudden he just came walking over here
dude he okay so when I am at my computer
desk I have my monitors and there's this
much of a gap between my monitor and my
sound mixer and he worms through it on
top of the sound board and just like
appears underneath anonymity oh wow this
is timed okay we all know refresh no no
no refresh refresh that's not fair fair
crack at this Tony told me to press play
quiz all right first place what the
office trivia here we go all right
Mastiff easy oh sorry it looks like you
have about twenty minutes I think for
the whole thing oh [ __ ] okay [ __ ] talk
all right I think we're answering what
is Dwight's middle name Kurt with a ke
ke you are team mmm-hmm
that was correct this office worker
originally applied for a job in the
warehouse
Darryl how do I spell that da r yl or
two R's how do you think are yl Darryl I
don't know how useful I don't know how
do you spell his name I don't know can I
search how they spell his name I can't
do it's why it's y da rry I think is it
look right with two hours yeah why don't
you type I'll type it da are Ryo I think
that's it
surprise done I don't know we literally
can't move on to the next question until
you figure out there well Darryl two
hours da r r yl y Oh Darryl it's not
correct da r yl d AR y L that's not
correct what oh oh oh my god no no Kevin
Kevin Kevin correct Jesus Christ that
was a [ __ ] that was a curveball cake
go keep going come on come on okay the
name of Angela's cat Dwight kills
sprinkles
wrinkles is correct the name of the cat
Dwight tries to give to Angela garbage
that's correct
I know I've had three affairs is the
question I've had three affairs
that's the question what's the context
none look at it
Oh like that character has had three
affairs yes I'm pretty sure not correct
what Angela not correct okay so maybe
that was too isn't it the redheaded lady
Meredith yeah that's all right
yeah that's not right I want to say
Donna cuz that's the one who has an
affair with Michael not maybe Michael
this is hard I don't know I've had three
affairs not correct mm-hmm
who's had three affairs Oh Dwight no no
no no that's not right
what's the name of the guy that was
sleeping with Angela's politician Oh
Oscar
no he hasn't had three affairs though
it's not him no I'm just naming people
yeah I mean I guess we got this one
wrong can we move on in that no hey Kel
no I can't I originally worked in the
steel industry before dunder mifflin
Charles miner Saticoy steel based on the
streets Saticoy that where they film off
history and you're telling me to hurry
up and then you're doing just like that
sir I thought Phyllis was a lesbian when
she got her hair cut short Michael said
that correct Karen became Regional
Manager at this Dunder Mifflin branch
Utica Utica no you did Utica you don't
even know anything about you because
I've seen New York you know about okay I
was fired in the episode Halloween
what's his [ __ ] name he sat near
Creed no I know can I go back okay so
what is Dwight's mom's name Henrietta
you sure about that
Henrietta is not correct Oh what damn it
this is tough okay hold on hon I got
this um Jim Jim says it at some point
what is the what is it White's mom's
what is Roy's brother's name oh my god I
don't know I avoid it
this actress appeared both in the office
and Parks and Recreation the actress yes
um what's her name the what's her
real-life name what character does you
care and Perkins on Parks and Rec that's
Rashida's rashida Jones that's it I'll
help you thank you thank you
team effort that's not correct though Oh
Ann Perkins then no no no I am Parker
karen filipelli Karen maybe who's Karen
maybe I spell Rasheeda wrong yeah I did
oh sorry Michael identifies with this
actor slash actress
Timothy Olyphant how dispel all of them
Oly PHA ante not correct is that on his
name Tim Timothy moving on I thought
that was right you look up how to spells
and he can't look about as Paul's name
Julie no you gotta write the rest of the
quiz at one point this characters
license-plate red new MGR manager Andy
no no no no creak creak creak creak
creepers okay who was the ex-convict Don
it was named Donald no that's not no was
named you got a lot of questions left
Julie okay 13 minutes I'll come back
nominal the minority executive that's
all it says Kelly correct this character
hates monkeys hates monkeys skip this
character sells valuables on ebay Oh
Angela she sold her engagement ring not
correct but this character creed bratton
transfers his debt to this alter ego
Charles Edwards Edward Charles Snyder
Edward Charles Snyder it's not right
Edward Charles Snyder yeah Edward
Charles Snyder not correct all right
fine
do you have another answer Charles
Edward yeah try that one well that's
correct
it's William Charles Schneider though we
got it right though okay what's Holly's
middle name in I don't know hey I think
it's an a probably not in no I don't
skip was Pam's middle name
we know what's Donna's husband's name
Donna Donna [ __ ] the baseball coach just
type baseball coach see what comes up no
I don't know I'm getting so bad I'm so
embarrassed okay
what is Ryan's middle name middle name
what is the name of Toby's fictional
detective in his novel chad flenderman
correct what movie was the office
watching for movie Mondays when
interrupted by Jan varsity blues God
direct what is the name of the
supermarket where Michael finds out Jan
is pregnant it's like a name it's like
Bob's or something it's not Bob's though
[ __ ] I don't know skip
this episode was guest directed by the
force awakens director JJ Abrams threat
level midnight no because that would be
fictional this is an actually guest
directed spot hasn't it you're guessing
the name of an episode I think guests
directed by JJ Abrams one doll [ __ ] did
you type that didn't work okay
who hired Darryl ed truck
correct Michael's nickname for the
warehouse the slums or something let me
call it the slums okay oh no I don't
know the theme of Pam and Jim's room at
Dwight's bed-and-breakfast irrigation
yes omen make sure you're typing it
right correct
which Harry Potter book was Dwight
reading to Jim and Pam Prisoner of
Azkaban okay please don't make you type
in Azkaban I can't how do you spell that
it's not letting me
type it in is not right or I'm spelling
it what is Dwight's salary in his
fantasy about a B&B he'll $80,000 a year
correct like didn't know where to put
the number or the word okay this in was
put out of business by bad reviews on
TripAdvisor
the stock in it's not the stock SS t ALK
it's John China maybe it's not the stock
it's he's talking to it's correct oh it
is okay I have to type the whole this is
weird if they do entire you should
really do this okay what famous singer
does Andy say owns the same Mac as Aaron
John no not John Legend um I don't
[ __ ] know okay he says wow that's
cool computer what's her name has that
or something
okay go damn it what type of car does
Dwight drive he drives a Thunderbird a
t-bird thunder what do you want me to
just under bird doesn't work okay I'm
bad at the game keep going
t-bird doesn't work either I Drive a red
Chevy Corvette it's a Corvette no no no
that's not the answer I don't know the
answers this is the next question
Oh Todd Packer Todd correct I'm allergic
to walnuts ah Kevin please gonna power
through correct I'm allergic to peanuts
DeAngelo Vickers I don't know how to
spell these people's names
let me do it
Oh D'Angelo it worked I went to the same
high school as Toby hmm Michael did
Michael and Phil let's go to the same
high school is Toby Michaels not correct
Phyllis Phyllis not correct no I have no
idea
Dwight Andy and Erin play slash sing
this song together in the break room
what's that song goes everybody dance
now it's called everybody dance now try
that no that's what he plays by himself
okay
don't know okay what is the boom
microphone operator really okay sorry
with any of it what is the boom
microphone operator who was fired in
season 9 this is awful that I don't know
this um Brian oh my god I do know it
correct what is the name of the
assistant who will Ferrell's character
hires the one who worked at
Anthropologie what's her name
Emma I don't know Lauren god damn it
okay what is the name of Holly's
boyfriend in Nashua DJ that rat aj that
right now just aj okay that's correct
all right you have five minutes left and
I've done as I can go back yeah
what is the guy's name on Halloween the
dude who gets fired is it Dean can you
go back and check if the guy who gets
fired at Halloween his name is Dean it's
not Dean but it's something like Dean
what's the name that's like Dean nice I
have to find that question it's a D or
something
it's at the very top I think mm-hmm it's
not Dean it's not Dean what is that
what's the name that's like Dean what do
you mean like the same energy of Dean
[Music]
okay just go down the list and read me a
question I've got three Affairs who the
[ __ ] has had three affairs um Robert
Lipton or Robert California Oh
oh my god I know who it is I know who it
is it's um blanking so art okay keep
going I'll think of her
I'll think of her name what's Dwight's
mom's name Henrietta damn it um I don't
know if it's Henrietta I could be
spelling it wrong time okay cuz I'm
spelling it like the place like where I
grew up
what is her name dude I the boss who
come I like she's such a big character
in the show and such a great actress the
one with the two dogs
that's Dwight's mom no no that's the one
who has had three affairs I think Kathy
Bates yeah yeah so what's her [ __ ]
goddamn name she introduces herself and
then Daryl says her name Joe Joe Joe
Bennett that's her name Joe
just type Joe for three Affairs okay jo
e Joe Joe it's not jo jo look correct is
her name Joe Bennett I didn't try typing
that in that's not correct
don't always have the Reavers if it
wasn't her I thought it was her what's
Roy's brothers name Donald Donald it's
literally a crapshoot I have no clue
Michael identifies with this actor slash
actress
I'm stum do you know Timothy Olyphant is
no let me just look up a picture of him
this does not count as cheating I'm just
letting a picture of Timothy Olyphant
okay it's not Jesus tude did you spell
it like that yeah well did exactly like
that here I'll type it in oh maybe maybe
it's a different scene that I'm thinking
of cuz this is Timothy all offense
character he's like does he remind you
of anyone me but maybe it's talking
about when he actually says I am like
this actor no I believe you what can you
really in what actor does this Michael
Scott Michael identifies with this actor
slash actress Oh Beyonce know that she's
not an actress yes she is don't get it
twisted
no I'm not Beyonce you've never seen
Carmen yeah we're not talking about
Sarah hip hop hip hopera that she was in
she was in films you're here Beyonce
blabbering is distracting me from
thinking no offense you have a minute in
23 seconds what actor okay keep going on
list who was the ex-convict how do I not
know his name
so stupid it's not the character hates
monkeys Meredith no idea character sells
valuables on eBay Meredith um that's
correct
what yeah okay I could Gore holly's
middle name thirty Seconds skip
Pam's middle name forget skip Donna's
husband's name Adam Adam oh I thought it
was out of Ryan's middle name nine
seconds Jonathan it's not correct okay I
am done you're not [ __ ] difficult oh
my god that was difficult
you got 53% the average score is 44%
that's so embarrassing there were so
many okay I can do they have answers now
who got fired on Halloween just I'll get
there chillin oh I need to know that one
first no sorry I've had three affairs is
Stanley Hudson oh my god duh am i right
guys oh no he's the biggest dog in the
show okay oh I was fired in the episode
Halloween it's Dean Dean energy I told
you it's addy named Devin yeah Dean is
it similar when I said what's the name
like Dean you were supposed to reply
Devin and then we were supposed to get
that right no you were supposed to get
the answer
Devin okay you were close but Dwight's
mom's name is Hedda Bock Roy's brother's
name is Kenny that's such a stupid
question that's like how many blades of
grass were in the baseball episode what
a stupid question who wrote that chill
out I'm not gonna show up
Michael identifies with Meryl Streep
dammit dude okay
the ex-convict is Martin Martin [ __ ]
Martin the character that hates monkeys
is Michael why I don't know
Holly's middle name is partridge pants
when'll name is Morgan neither of those
ever came up once
Donna's husband's name is Shan Shan the
baseball coach Ryan's middle name is
Bailey I knew that one Bryan Bailey
Howard damn it okay
the name of the supermarket where
Michael finds out Janet G it's a G name
is H name G name am i annoying you yes
okay what is rarities G names I told you
it has Dean energy okay Devon has Dean
energy this episode was guest directed
by JJ Abrams
it's called cocktails that's crazy I had
no idea
wild Michaels nickname for the warehouse
it's start out but it says the blank
house like the four letters like the
bad-word house they were reading the
deathly hallows by the way not the
Prisoner of Azkaban which you made me
type in like seven times she's attempt
to write I'm just kidding I'm sorry the
Harry Potter book that Dwight was
reading yeah to Jim and Pam at his farm
was the deathly hallows mm-hm
I think the Prisoner of Azkaban comes up
in two different episodes that's my
might have been why I have said that one
the famous singer does Andy say owns the
same Mac as Erin is Gwen Stefani
goddamnit the type of car
Dwight drives is a 1987 Pontiac trans-am
I just feel every every word is a dagger
into my heart Katie went to the same
high school as Toby Katie wait that the
bag salesman you're asking me like I
know
okay Dwight Andy and Erin play / sing
country roads in the break room together
oh my god I thought I was thinking of
cafe disco oh my god oh my god I love
that scene okay God God the name of the
assistant who will Ferrell's character
hires is Jordan I knew that too okay
that's it
this was miserable I should have done so
much better it's okay though
everything's fine
because we're all gonna die one day
right oh my god you want to know what
came up right after this is so hard
what Seinfeld fictional movies quiz you
have to be so hardcore Seinfeld
fictional you know all the movies that
they're always talking about seeing in
that show like a young girl strange
erotic journey from Milan to Mintz I
know what that one is that Rochelle
Rochelle you wanna do that just for a
second
I want to see fresh Al Rochelle Rochelle
fictional movie sure though ROC a GL le
I just tried that Stanley has had three
affairs dude Devon plans to see this
movie were affected by Jerry having to
dog-sit
although he eventually ends up seeing it
twice idiot farfel is the name of the
dog what's the movie he was gonna say no
exactly it's so hard that one's not fair
Elaine chooses us to see this instead of
the English Patient
so hard Susan gets upset because Jerry
and Elaine don't stop talking during
this movie this is insane yeah I don't
get that the Puerto Rican Day George in
Puerto Rican Day George gets a laugh by
yelling that's gotta hurt at an
opportune time during this movie you're
supposed to remember the fictional movie
they're watching so silly it's all
background I know why do you even pay
attention to that right someday I'm
gonna ace that quiz alright I'll go back
what well and someday I'm gonna order
some post mates Wow
as you guys know I love pad thai I often
order pad thai on post mates and you can
too
right now post mates is being super
awesome and careful with their nan
delivery's so when you order everything
gets left right outside the door you
don't have to touch anyone or make
contact with anyone they're very careful
it's awesome they also post mates pickup
which you can use to good take out pay
your local favorite restaurants
so you drive up get out your car pick it
up and go right so it's nice and safe
and it's still a way to conveniently get
you all of your favorite foods very fast
because you want them now you don't want
your favorite foods later postmates
snows that so they make it happen
they also don't just deliver pad thai
they make my life easier and your life
potentially to from delivering things
from the grocery store or from a
drugstore like Walgreens right so they
can give you things that isn't just
takeout food and they make it super
convenient and quick so right now you
just download the post mates app on iOS
or Android find your favorites and get
anything you want very fast use code
Jenna Julian within the app to get a
hundred and ten dollars of free delivery
credits here first seven days to start
your deliveries download the app right
now and get started or check out the
information in the description check it
out post mates also guys when you're
looking to buy some new undies or even
some onesies or some brats or apparently
some rompers go-to meal this sold out
right now well you know restock them
please thank you
me Andes is amazing we've been wearing
their underwear and others for many
years three times often con it's hard to
believe but then you put your hands on
it and it is truly magically soft okay
my undie collection has grown immensely
ever since I discovered me Andes and
yours can too right now you just get go
to me Andes calm even if you don't even
view whatever reason don't want to use
our URL but you should go to me Andes
dot-com you get site-wide savings early
access and free shipping when you sign
up with a membership for me undies if
you use our URL which is me undies meu n
di es comm slash Jenna Julian you get
15% off your first pair free shipping
and 100% satisfaction guarantee so check
it out go to me and these browse around
add things to that cart you're gonna
like it you're up for summer okay even
if you know we might not be going
anyplace
you still need some comfortable
underwear and other things so go to me
and he's calm / tianj oh and check it
out thank you alright deep breath I
wanted to do better damn pretty yet
Devon and Martin the two [ __ ] season
1 characters I couldn't remember I'm
bummed at the the thing I'm probably
most bummed about is questions like the
Stanley affair like they're so right in
front of my nose that I'm just like
thinking all around I'm like what could
it be whose but it's Stanley he [ __ ]
but I think that was fun that was that
was the most fun I've had taking an
office quiz even though I'd got only 50
was hard it was a challenge yet made me
work for it and all the watch throughs
I've done where I'm like in each seen
him like huh
what did I miss last time this kind of
pays off you know things like that thank
you for thank you for indulging me
you're welcome to him and for typing in
all the answers that was frustrating I
love you I would have done it for you
though in fact I will do it for you
right now with a Seinfeld superfan quiz
I'm not gonna do that well I just like
casually watch I don't rewatch for the
sake of paying closer attention you know
I throw it on and fall the [ __ ] to sleep
well we can we can try it out and if
it's barbeque or an easier one yeah
we'll play play together if this is
really hard we can go to an easier one
how well do you know sign phone okay
what Manhattan neighborhood did Jerry
reside in Lower East Side Upper East
Side Upper West Side or Soho no I think
Upper East
um I think West eating Upper West what's
the first one Lower East Upper East
Upper West Upper West correct thank you
which Seinfeld care writer voiced George
Steinbrenner on and off from seasons
five through nine that's Larry David
right yeah why don't I get to take the
quiz oh sorry I thought we were teens
together I'll come in for assistance if
you're struggling in life and what is it
yeah Larry David sorry
guest star Teri Hatcher's breasts as
confirmed by her character Sidra in
season fours of the implant or not only
real but they're fabulous well there's
four there's four options and none of
them are fabulous unforgettable tastic
can I read them I just did that whole
quiz for you be nice to me I am I'm let
me read it's a multiple choice well you
didn't tell me that the whole thing is
vocal tryst unforgettable exceptional
remarkable or spectacular spectacular
nice in season six is the doorman Frank
Costanza wants to name the chest support
garment he and Kramer invented the man's
ear but Kramer prefers a the bro be the
breast man if you know it I can't I just
answer you can answer it
okay sorry you can answer it I thought I
would read the multiple choice because
it's multiple choice but if you don't
want me to just tell me how can I want
he wants a call at the bro correct
which of these occupations did George's
alias art vandal a not purport to
Petelin okay you can read the choices
now because I have to say the one that
he did not
latex salesman novelist garbage man
importer/exporter
he's definitely an importer cast such
nonsense garbage in I don't think is the
one I think that's the answer cuz I
don't know about latex salesmen what was
the other one novelist that sounds about
right
garbage man correct you're a hundred was
arena the Tao of Jerry Newman is the
blank to his Superman Lex Luthor nice
good the last Seinfeld episode written
or co-written by Larry David was I have
no idea the finale the invitations the
Cadillac or the contest mater the
Cadillac encouraged what is it it's not
telling
okay I didn't I don't really pay
attention to who directs the same yeah
what's a weird one in later seasons
Kramer frequently sought the counsel of
an excitable attorney who parodied which
team member which member sorry of OJ
Simpson's defense team so I have to name
a real defense attorney right now yes
okay I'm gonna read the sheriff Robert
Kardashian Alan Dershowitz Johnnie
Cochran F lee Bailey I have no idea
because I was a child when that was
going in yeah I didn't even realize I
was a parity whatever is whatever one's
name is Cochran is who he's the person
correct Johnnie Cochran's nice did you
know he was a parody character I don't
think so yeah Elaine's preferred big
salad is her her illustration like a
salad only bigger comma blank I'm gonna
read them yeah like a salad only bigger
with more of everything like a salad
only bigger with more ingredients like a
salad only bigger with lots of stuff in
it like a salad only bigger like a big
salad like a big salad or it's lots of
stuff in it I think it was lots of stuff
in it like a big salad was incorrect
okay but I think you're at the same time
Elaine has many talents including which
one was it
it doesn't give like I press it's once
it's wrong it's wrong like I get it okay
we'll probably find out at the end
Elaine as many talents including copy
editing and recreational skiing but as
we learn in season eights the little
kicks this skill is not one of them
dancing I'm pretty sure it's dancing
chef present yeah correct
nice midway through season eight
Kramer lost plenty of sleep thanks to
this fledgling fast-food chain chains
new episode a mobile left it exclaimed
cuz little no no do tell them told mr.
marbles little screws ventriloquist
puppet thank you just keeps in his
apartment
and Jerry crashes there here's the noise
like this marble sounds like when he
walks that literally is what he sounds
like the ventriloquist character the
future primetime TV star landed an early
role as a neo-nazi in season three's the
limo I'm supposed to name a daytime
actress I like I know what the actress
looks like but I do not know her name
it's they're all men do you mean to read
oh sorry I don't know his name
Matthew Fox Peter Krause Matthew Perry
or Josh Charles go with what read the
first two again
Matthew Fox Peter Krause Matthew Perry
the first one Matthew Fox incorrect I
don't know any soap opera stars meaning
go ahead primetime TV in season fours
the Cheever letters what article of
clothing did Jerry inquire about during
dirty talk with girlfriend Sandra what
are the choices
her mother's panties wait no one are
only that I know it's an episode okay
Zee Cavett cavalry cavalry cheese the
puffy shirt or edible underwear
I don't know mother's panties it is the
medicine Jerry loves being friends with
famous ex New York met Keith Henderson
Keith Henderson sorry but box at
Henderson's request - I'm gonna read
them I can read that better Jerry loves
being friends with famous ex New York
met Keith Henderson Henderson
but box that's a weird way of describing
the question but box at Henderson's
request - I'm not even reading right his
name's Hernandez I'm so sorry
Hernandez Keith Hernandez mm-hmm support
his second spitter theory dog said his
poodle set him up with Elaine or help
him move dog said his poodle no what is
it
okay which pendant publishing office
made to George sleep with leading to his
eventual firing in season three's the
red dot
I don't know Susan mr. Lippman secretary
the receptionist the cleaning lady the
mail lady I love how she at the end
she's like what is that spots the red
dot Cosmo Kramer there's a Cosmo :
Kramer blank : Seinfeld Jerry Gerald
Jerome jerath Geralyn Jerome
nice I thought it was Geralyn season
two's the jacket concludes with Elaine's
hard-ass father humming a show tune from
which Broadway smash want me to read
them sure cats
Miss Saigon cabaret lame is um cabaret I
don't know I do not know the answer
rock hammer oh okay sick hear ye hear ye
it's a Festivus for the rest of us Bates
nice the airing of grievances Festivus
for the rest of us Serina dunno yes
Susan dies at the end of season sevens
the invitations but Jerry also meets his
exact female counterpart played by this
comedic actress
that's Janeane Garofalo hailed it well
done well done
season 4 is the Bubble Boy I featured
which Caddyshack co-star as the
particular immune deficient teenager's
father
Shelby sorry no go ahead
Chevy Chase the actors names yeah the
actors ones hard like the rashida Jones
when that was impossible okay Brian
doyle-murray Rodney Dangerfield Michael
O'Keefe I don't know two and four go
with two I don't know Brian
Marie yay it's correct ding-ding-ding
good job I wish that was a more fun
question but okay actress Kristin Bauer
van Straten
whose man hands-free cherien season aids
the bizarro Jerry later scared
innumerable men half to death as Pam on
which hit series now you're asking me a
question about a different show tone
arena
American Horror Story Dexter true blood
or lost literally just push any of those
buttons because I do not Dexter it
didn't work nothing happened
while dining at Mendis in season six is
of the soup
Jerry's stand-up nemesis Kenny banya
raves that they make the best blank in
the city
salmon sorbet swordfish or steak mmm
salmon
incorrect yeah Kramer rescued the set of
which talk show from a dumpster the Merv
Griffin Show yes take that one nice face
with the possible shortage of one of her
favorite products elaine started using
this term when assessing potential
suitors
well done I've got 33 out of 50 does it
even tell you the answers now or no no
that's so stupid Wow
it's an online quiz with multiple choice
and doesn't tell you the right answer
when you get one wrong
no and half of the questions are about
other things my god and written to like
confuse you yeah they're written so
poorly Wow
I could have been more fun but it was
that could have been more fun sorry if I
wasn't reading it the right way or
trying to make it like I was trying my
best it was just kind of up in the air
I'm sorry it's okay okay don't take the
vulture quiz on Seinfeld everybody it's
not that great it's okay it's a little
bit confusing very very very confusing
yeah
I think it could be more user-friendly
it's not very user friendly and I wish
you told you the answers at least the
one even the one that I gave you when
you type in the questions at the end it
shows you all the answers well that's
what a quiz is supposed to do so you
learn from it otherwise what's the point
in taking all I need you don't get to
learn peach they have a they have a
marker in their brains when the podcast
is over and then when it's over they
jump up on the table because do you have
fun Julian yeah that's fun with your
office quiz yeah it was hard it was
[ __ ] I got rekt but it was fun I was
hoping that Seinfeld quiz was just like
something like some of those questions
were good and like what I was hoping
even if I didn't know the answer you
know like a nice casual quiz none of
this mess why'd y'all give me a mess
quiz yeah and I also don't think a
superfan qualifies as someone who knows
references that leave the show yeah like
that doesn't make you a superfan that
makes you someone who knows about
entertainment and actors and shows that
are not that show yeah get him right PG
but yeah I mean it was fun she jumped up
and kissed you in the middle of yeah I
was like at the exact hour mark $20 $20
$20 you're cut off you're cut off I have
to Sunday you don't get it you don't
have internet access well thank you for
playing thank you for reading The Office
quiz to me I'm dealing with a shitty
Seinfeld quiz I tried my best
it was so fun it was fun yeah Kenny
Rogers Timbo's mm-hmm well we'll be back
next week for another podcast no we
won't
next week is a holiday what is the
holiday I don't know okay Labor Day or
something right is that no Memorial Day
it's Memorial Day I was confused those
two it is Memorial Day so next week
we're off for Memorial Day so enjoy a
podcast free week
have some good food do what you're gonna
do for Memorial Day stay safe we love
you guys thanks for hanging and we'll
see you on the next episode which is the
week after Memorial Day sounds good
[Music]